Speaker 1: Okay.
Very quickly.
Trump's approval has plunged to its lowest
in a year.
Now I'm going to show you what the number
is.
And the number is actually kind of scary.
Newsweek reports Donald Trump's approval rating
plunges to lowest point in over a year.
This is based on an NBC News poll, 54% negative
approval rating and 34% positive for Trump.
Okay.
Trump had the same 54% negative in August,
but a slightly higher positive of 36.
Trump also had 36 positive in May and March
37 in January.
Doesn't matter.
So there's two things going on here.
Number one, clearly, to some degree, the country
is reacting to the absurdity of what this
man has become.
It's a joke, complete and total joke.
And more and more people have moved away from
Trump.
That's a good thing.
The scary thing is how insane is this country?
That more than a third of the country still
approves of Trump, who has now been out of
office for 20 months, who has apparently done
so many things that go against the fundamentals
of what this country is based on, both in
spirit and in practice when it comes to the
law, humiliates us regularly and himself on
the world stage.
Still, as a former president.
And more than a third of the country when
asked, says, I think I think Trump's great.
I highly approve of Trump.
Yeah, he's fantastic.
And there is a there is an excerpt from a
book written after World War Two that describes
how just ordinary Germans in Nazi Germany
descended into a state where there was relatively
high approval of Hitler and his Nazi regime.
And you can Google this.
It's the University of Chicago has an excerpt
from the book is They Thought They Were Free
the Germans 1933 to 1945.
The book is by Milton Maier.
And there's an excerpt called But Then It
Was Too Late.
And it talks about the slow descent into.
Yeah, I mean, I guess I do approve even though
if you if we now went back six years and described
what Trump is now, you wouldn't say, would
you approve of that?
You wouldn't get 34 or 36% approval.
You wouldn't.
But there's this slow descent, slow descent
into madness.
One other piece I think is a good idea to
read if you want to understand what's going
on is by Alex Shepard in New Republic it's
called Donald Trump is more deranged than
ever.
As his approval ratings sink, the president
is more and more unhinged and more willing
to indulge his most dangerous followers.
And that's very relevant to you know, we saw
this Q9 moment during Trump's Ohio rally over
the weekend.
Also extraordinarily dangerous.
That article, which we will link to instructive
and informative and very, very scary.
Let's take a quick break.
We're going to be right back after this